[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to
wine library tv hello everybody and
welcome to the what i don't even
remember hello everybody and welcome to
wine library tv yep ready
yeah hello everybody and welcome to wine
library tv i am your host gary
vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 1003 drock
three of the thunder show aka
the internet's most passionate wine
program and isn't this [ __ ] fantastic
and you got to beat that drock cause i
don't curse on the thunder show
a lot of things have changed through
that half decade of doing this show
every day five days a week i mean it
five years
and we got a thousand shows in it and i
only did it monday through friday so i
was
consistent i miss so many of you all the
vayniacs out there and welcome to all
the new people i'm sure
the team it is not eric castner it is
not chris
mott to clear that up that was not my
mother ma i was saying mott
it is drock in the building who if you
watched my transition after
wine library tv in business and
entrepreneurial land has been by my side
for a long time and we are excited to do
episode
1003. if you look back at episode 1001
or 1002 i ended up episode 1000
um i talked about doing these
occasionally like barbara walters
specials and i'll do them four times a
year
well i think it's the first episode i'm
doing in four years
so a lot's been going on the jets
continue to struggle we are 0 and 10 uh
in this season so i know that you know
it was really funny the the episodes of
winery tv we're doing some good years of
jets football
it's been rough we have not made the
playoffs now for 10 straight years
so maybe i should start doing wine
library tv again because
06 to 11 was like a great run of jets
football
maybe that's actually the missing part
maybe wine library tv
is the key to jets good football anyway
everyone's good
thank you so much much to all of you
that have signed up for wine tax that's
the big innovation back of the shop
vaynermedia and all this other stuff has
happened there's plenty to catch up on
but i don't want to take up this time
what i want to do is do this holiday
episode if nothing else i can do this
once a year to talk about holiday wine
what's going on in the wine world
so many of you know i started a brand
called empathy wines we sold it a
consolation
um that's been exciting and and since
i've last left you i've been more and
more into wine i drink more wine
when i was doing wine library tv i never
had wine at dinner it was so much my
profession i
never drank wine at dinner i now drink
wine all the time at dinner
and i've been more into the wine world
as a consumer and a lot of things have
changed for example
why we chose wine number one and i'm
excited to taste it
is as many of you may remember and this
is the pfeiffer pavett
night 2018 napa valley 20 30
depending on where you buy it from 91
points wine spectator
talk about a fun wine to start with
during my great
and fun and amazing five-year run on
wine library tv i'm sorry
the jets bucket is around today we have
a like a coffee grinder spittoon but
we will find the jets bucket if we get
this going
talk about something that has changed in
my opinion and the markets
i along with the american consumer
during 2006 to 2011 my golden ear of
wine library tv
were not about that napa valley or
california
sauvignon blanc as a matter of fact i
think i famously at least
to myself said that it was that all the
sauvignon blanc
all the sauvignon blanc in california
should be ripped up and replanted a
different grape that's how down i was
that's how high i was on saucer in new
zealand sauvignon blanc
and and that's how i felt over the last
18 months i've been
stunned my by my overall appreciation
for california samuel blanc i think the
style has evolved
more balanced less sugary less goopy the
wine world itself has
gone and followed a lot of food and
health trends
if you look at kind of like clean eating
kind of
vegan life like just really not you know
just actually being thoughtful about
what you're putting in your body you
look at the natural wine craze
you look at the alcohol levels in wine
coming down in california
more balance and and it's been really
interesting and fun to watch and
you know it's funny i'm curious how i'm
going to review this wine i hope i don't
pan it and and i i'm happy to as you
know for everybody's watching
i'm excited for one of these wines to
get some heat or we could go for
four we could go for four you never
really know but but i want to say before
i get into the wine in case i don't like
this one
news excuse me california sauvignon
blanc has made a tremendous
comeback in overall consumption and has
been something i've been lately fond of
and
this is a tremendous consistent producer
so let's give it a sniffy snack
on the nose i get a little bit of like
oyster shell you know very fresh
very you know sea ocean life
i get a hint of uh melon call it
cantaloupe on the nose
little hint of lemon and lime coming
through
so you know the classic oysters and
cantaloupe
with a little sprite port on top of it
nice snows let's give it a whirl
uh
gorgeous acidity throughout this wine a
banana
peel meets granny smith
apple mid palette huge acid on the
finish
i still am tasting it gorgeous acidity
now why is the city important when i
taste this wine
i know i can use it to cut through a lot
of seafoods
scallops oysters clams you get into that
seafood life even
i'm thinking lobster tail in butter but
this wine has the acidity cut through
and match that wine not be overpowered
by the food
but the wine itself is balanced and
won't overpower the wine
no alcohol in the flavor beautiful apple
i really get
the granny apple smith apple on this
beautiful finish if you just like a nice
fresh salad
i think this wine would pair extremely
well at 20 to 30 bucks
a really strong value doesn't have the
minerality of a great sansaire
that i'm a fan of in that 30 40 range
but this stands up and this continues
the momentum that i told you
spectator gave a 91 points to me this is
a 90 pointer as well i'll give it 90
plus
being a little tough against the
spectator right now but this is a
beautiful sony blank and if you can find
it
under 20 this can get into case wine
life during the summer
um this is really nice
if you're watching i don't know if we're
putting this out or what are we doing
when are we putting it out
thursday night yeah i mean if you can if
we put this out on monday or tuesday of
next week
and you can pick up this wine for
thanksgiving if they have in your local
store
this is a perfect stuffing this is a
perfect aperitif when you have people
over not a whole lot of people over
during covid but
this is a tremendous pool timeline
like this is summer in a bottle
beautiful wine nice complexity great
start
glad i feel like one of those episodes
um
drock on one of my comeback episodes 101
or one or two all the wines didn't do
well or something i felt like a
real debbie downer wow like that you
know remember her face
but you know like real debbie downer but
let's get into this one i've been
hearing
huge hype about this marne
renee campbell ranch pinot noir 92
points wine spectator 50 bucks
sonoma coast pinot i think
i had this you know it's funny that they
put this in the box i
thought i'd do this for a monthly wine
club if you haven't signed up for my
wine of the month club
go to wine library.com i thought i may
be hearing so much about marne in
general
i there's a dark horse chance i've had
this wine already
um let's see if i'm consistent or so
everybody's part of the wine club dig up
the videos
they don't recall poo
this just pinot noir if you remember
that's why i have the pinot and the
barolo
in the heyday of my 2006-2011 wine
library tv
pinot was exploding burgundy was
exploding and i was talking about barolo
being the next thing to explode well
sure enough you know i like a good
monday morning quarterback
here we are nine ten years later and we
nailed that barolo
exploded in value um we were so on it i
hope a lot of you followed me back then
and
loaded up on barolo bros you could buy
for 40 60 bucks back then
are now 3 400 a bottle it changed
and so i thought it'd be fun to have
here and then some super cold california
wine that i know
for the holidays buy for your boss buy
for yourself kind of
buy for christmas and all the other
holiday dinners so we have a big
insignia to wrap us up but the barolo's
here for that reason and we have a pinot
for that reason these are two bookend
wines
since i've been missing you this was the
exploding wine that emerged pinot
sideways i don't drink merlot all that
and barolo has become the fancy of the
wine world in the last five to ten years
so excited about this marnet single
vineyard campbell ranch beautiful nose
little bacon fat huge strawberries
just gorgeous feet strawberry fields
forever
wow
wow
since i've last loved left you i've had
the luxury of traveling the world quite
a bit
and staying in some really really really
really fancy
hotels this wine's silkiness
is like the nicest silkiest sheets
from the most expensive ritz carlton or
four seasons you can imagine just silk
all the way through
beautiful red fruit raspberry
strawberries throughout i get a little
rose petal
on the mid palette and a wonderful beef
jerky like premium beef jerky this is
not macho man randy savage
slim jim yeah beef jerky this is the
really expensive 38 at the fancy food
show beef jerky on the mid pallet
comes together in this incredible 50
pinot noir that in my opinion
rivals hundred dollar red burgundies
that i have every day
of the week aka 15 times a year this is
extraordinary
92 points wine spectator whereas i
thought the spectator was a half a point
high here
i think they're two full points low here
to me this is a 94 point pinot noir
and anything and anywhere you can get it
under 50
is a humongous buy you may you're
probably gonna see this wine if you
write it down
on a restaurant list at a good wine
program more than you're gonna find it
online or at a retailer um
but i mean if you can get this for less
than a buck
fifty a bottle on a wine list it is your
wine of the night this is
drinking great now but if you go out and
find this 18
2018 vintage wine and you're really into
pinot and there it is 13
8. this is the beauty i'm telling you
the wines have come back to balance
since i left um if you you know some of
these were 15
fives pinots too much alcohol too much
makeup too much extra you know the
world's gone extravagant you know you go
on instagram it's a little bit glammed
up it's a little bit
fake life but the wines have come back
to match our food life cleaner simpler
realer
and i like that 94 points on this wine
this is a steal to me
pick it pick it up if you can find it
if you drink sea smoke costa brown
rockiole like this is this is a real
that's a beast of a wine really good all
right i'm super excited about this
copo 2015 barolo really fun vintage
30 to 40 90 points wide enthusiasts 13.5
alcohol
big fan of this producer have always
been um
loved the late 90 versions earl 2001 of
this wine
really excited about this 15.
i've always liked this winery a lot now
because you can see color's a little
different not as pitch black as some
wines you're gonna see this color
that you're gonna see just black this is
more brownish um
and and red i love that i love that
copper i love barolo
nebiolo based which is the grape
not the kind of nose i would have
expected from this wine to be honest a
little tight
i've had some 15 barlows that have been
more exciting on the nose
yeah a little disappointing let me let
me warm it up a little
but tight tight like i used oysters
earlier you know that oyster that's not
fully open
and you're always wondering with your
friends like but it's kind of open like
should we eat it and you're kind of like
you're kind of a little scared you're
like it didn't open so maybe that's a
problem you know you know that you know
what i'm talking about
right drock with the clay you know i'm
always the one that's like i'll go there
that's probably why i throw up sometimes
at three o'clock in the morning from
food poisoning but like you know most
people pass that's what's going on here
this is like a tight
little clam and it may not be worth
entering
this appointment alert
disappointment alert a winery that i've
loved for years
a vintage i love a wine i just hyped up
for a minute before we got here
this wine is wildly underwhelming has
completely missed my expectations
this is like somebody you hired for your
business that you think is going to come
in and change the course of your company
and you realize by week two you need to
fire their sorry ass
this is a sorry ass wine 90.1 enthusiast
is completely overrated even at the
inexpensive 30 to 35 dollars that this
barolo can be
this is not this is not exciting
um
shockingly thin like kind of like
when you see your friend post covet and
they were working out and eating well
the whole year shockingly thin
this wine needs a lot more complexity
wow this is this is really not good
you know i'm a little rusty but this to
me is an 84 point wine
this wine away do not pick this up do
not buy this
alert your friends take a screenshot
text them this is a bad wine
things can change quicker drock that was
pretty tough
yeah it was rough man it was not this is
not a good wine one man's point of view
trust your own palette don't listen to
me don't listen to the wine spectator or
robert parker or your favorite sommelier
listen to yourself
that being said i've tasted a lot of
wine in my life
that's some garden all right the big dog
joseph phelps insignia 2014 an iconic
wine 97 points james suckling 97.1
advocate um eighty-seven percent
cabernet
nine percent petite for dough two
percent cabernet
franc two percent malbec two hundred
dollars a bottle
if you can even find one really excited
about this
1994 joseph phelps insignia this wine
put me on the map the 1994 of this wine
was a wine that i bought an enormous
amount of
everybody in the country was selling it
for 60 bucks i paid 39.99 a bottle
and i bought a 30 000 full page ad in
the new york times
and in that ad 80 of the real estate was
a picture of this wine
and it said 39.99 on sale and it was a
catapult moment in winelibrary.com's
history
so i will forever have enormous love for
joseph phelps insignia from that moment
it went on to become one of the most
iconic at that point it wasn't what it
is today
it was not on the opus one on the cayman
special so it was not in that league
but over the last 25 years it has built
itself up to being one of the most
significant wines in california and i'm
always so honored and excited to taste
it
great color remember i made that
reference earlier you can see the
difference
that you know light which is not bad
light is great just because the copper
wasn't a good wine in my opinion
i like light beaujolais pinot noir
barolo i love light
but this is dark powerhouse wine let's
give it a sniffy snip
now this is another thing that's been
interesting about the wine world
this comes across very perfume-oriented
very big flavor call it like jam i don't
know if you've you know
if you walked into like an old family
like your grandmother's
you know kitchen when she made a hand
made jam
now i had a soviet grandmother you know
my grandma esther passed away a couple
years ago my dad's mom
made she rest in peace but she was an og
like she would be like let's go outside
and pick raspberries
get all cut up and crap come back to the
kitchen
and like make that jam and um
and so i remember very authentic clean
like not go to whole foods and buy the
raspberry i mean
go outside or like when you're on the
highway driving there's some like wild
raspberries
pull over and pick them root saint john
we did that with it's called zvita boy
go google that that's like that magic
tea that my
great grandmother and grandmother
believed in the most like literally
grandma i broke my arm drink some zoda
boy grandma i think she has cancer drink
some sweet
like it solved everything so i remember
doing a lot of picking in the 80s
this smells like that to me a kitchen
where homemade jam is being made
however to go to the extreme in the
other direction
it also smells like do you remember now
in laters
the candy there's a candy named now in
laters
and like they were hard and you would
bite them but like i like it smells like
artificial candy so this is a really
interesting juxtaposition
on one side of the bouquet i smell that
authentic
berry but then i also get a lot of candy
i would for more contemporary candy
it smells like a bag of skittles so you
can feel the fakeness of the candy
interesting this is where the wine world
has gone a little bit
a little bit out of you know if you
watch wine library tv in that five year
my my palette bounced around a lot of
these
cult wines i loved them i hated them it
was like a love hate kind of thing
it's like it's like dessert like
sometimes a great piece of chocolate
cake
is just a good idea sometimes after you
eat it you want to punch yourself in the
face
that's what's happened with a lot of
these california wines
don't leave the witness drock
blackberry blackcurrant dark chocolate
high cocoa count so it's like real
chocolate flavors like not like
yay let's eat a kitkat no let's go into
like a really healthy store
and buy a bar for like 28 because
somebody climbed a mountain
and picked this and then like brought it
back on a propeller plane
in a jar and this is the cacao that
makes this 28
wildly overpriced hand curated
chocolate which is probably good for you
and you should probably like it but it
is bitter
that is mixed in with a lot of
strawberries and blueberries
blackberries
and cherries blackened red fruit in this
wine
however this is
really disappointing to say it is now
after tasting this wine i'm gonna give
it one more second but
this is gonna be a tough statement in my
opinion
it is now of my opinion that joseph
phelps insignia
and this and and i was a little bit
worried i wanted to try this
it's a really big time wine the ratings
are through the roots 96 97s everywhere
i have had two or three insignias since
i last left you in the last
decade where it really struck me like
this wine should really still be 39.99
not 200 bucks a bottle
i'm in my zone right now that was like i
was out
and like you know you know you're client
life now with vaynermedia so the clients
like google insignia i'm like all right
let's order a bottle of insignia
so i was very like in business mode not
really analyzing and rating a wine
as i sit here and analyze and rate this
wine
and i'm you know it's funny this is like
riding a bike
i'm really taken aback by this i i
believe that insignia
has jumped the shark like i feel like
i'm in the fonz right now
wearing a leather coat on a ramp
and but i also feel like i'm your friend
that tells you that santa claus doesn't
exist in second grade
this
is a wine that no long i mean this is
crazy that they want 200
for this when i think about the sheer
number of california cabernets
and red blends and wines
even from places like argentina
marama tuscany
that are 20 30 40 50 a bottle
i would argue that insignia has now
found itself
in that classic place of
colleges that aren't one of the top 10
in the country where you're going to
spend a ton of money and the diploma is
not worth it as much in the real world
fashion brands that cost eight hundred
dollars for a
scarf because it's got the right pattern
on it and everyone thinks it's
gucci and i mean slang term gucci not
specifically calling out gucci
this is a wine that is now a status in
my opinion
it's known by the big dogs and i think
people are paying at least a hundred
dollars
if not 125 dollars it's not 150
too much for this bottle of wine to me
this is far from a 96 to 97
and it's playing off its pedigree i
think that the world
respects the past too much that doesn't
mean disrespect
means it holds up yesterday instead of
looking at today
it's like being emotional about having
stores in the world of the internet
it's like being emotional about
instagram when tic toc is emerging
it is like not adjusting to post covert
life
and flying to every meeting in 2024 and
not doing zooms
i think insignia's holding on to a pass
of the late 90s and early 2000s
i think this is a 50 to 70 dollar wine
at this point i think this is a 90 point
wine
not a 97 point wine and i think i might
even be caught
being kind and 90 points this is a
colossal failure of a wine in my opinion
if it
thinks that it's worth 200 bucks this
days and i'm curious
for the comments and i'll look for the
shares but
this is what's wrong about consumer
products when you pay for reputation
versus what they're putting out
i think this is i think there's a lot of
wines in california 40 50 bucks
that are equal to this wine i really
genuinely do four really interesting
wines
cali blends barolo pinot and sauvignon
blanc
remember the themes of wine library tv
before i leave you try new things
trust your own palette you may disagree
with all four of my reviews here
try new things try new things try new
things that is how you become
great at wine because you get happiness
through it i wish you all
so much health so much health during
this holiday season
and remember i have a question of the
day and so here's my question since i
last saw you
what has become your favorite wine
whether it's an exact winery or a type
of wine
please leave that in the comments of
social media something that barely
existed
when we started wine library tv and
remember you
with a little bit of me we're changing
the wine world
whether they like it or not
[Music]
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon